[Music]
in picky eater news Oh God
my son is a picky picky
I mean that's cuz I always traumatized
with food I was really young are you
still picky and sausage Tom times with
food household I'll tell you later
why did they need a back story I get
this bread a teen went blind after
eating honey junk food since elementary
school
what is that really the cause because is
it really just it's gotta be like high
sodium or hot because I refuse to let go
against my addiction maybe they got
diabetes yes some of those have some of
those diseases like diabetes and and
high blood pressure can lead to
blindness my friend would eat a lot of
flamin hot cheetos and then he would
play video games and then he would rub
his eyes cheetos at my kids school
because of that it might be no for real
too many kids were eating them and then
rubbing their eyes and going to the
nurse's office is not fair we got too
many kids
that's natural selection though yeah
they go blind that's their own fault
that's the best junior high high school
snack yeah there was rap videos about it
Hot Cheetos and takis that's why I how
they go by this teenager here he has
only eaten five different foods since
elementary school and those are fries
Pringles
white bread and process a process ham
and sausages okay that's all he ate well
least he's got some protein what the
[ __ ] is that eat in the Oregon Trail
that was so much better [ __ ] meat the
tree three out of those five things is
just literally like [ __ ] carbs yes
nutrient Lascars yeah exactly so I can
see why is like nutrition different
there's no nutrients I watched a TLC my
strange addiction show where a cat ate a
pizza for 30 years every day
no a human being a person no so yeah so
yeah he was this man he was huge I ate a
pizza every day for 30 for 30 years and
or whatever for his whole life I think
any size more nutrients Pizza produce
enough food singing horseshit is he's
probably developed so it may be like
from 1 through 15 he got his ass beat he
ate a wide range of things and then he
made the choice after it was picky only
a pizza dude start from one from a
certain point yet so they took him to
the doctor and the doctors like oh [ __ ]
I can't believe it you're totally fine
he's like Seacrest
I would like pepperoni pizza Domino's
there's this famous autistic lady that
changed the whole entire industry for
how they butchered cows and stuff in
like she would only eat jell-o and and I
thought it was the funniest thing ever
cuz she would freak out when she sees
regular food but she would only be jello
so I'm like how the [ __ ] did she stay
alive she died on the inside only
because she was sprayed on with all
these other foods right yeah maybe they
were making vitamins and stuff
oh maybe no no has some kind of animal
stuff in the horse hug horse movies yeah
gelatin I think they just chuck a horse
at a wood chipper animation jello it
makes cat food and jello I swear that's
gotta be horses there Chuck whatever
what I look at my cats like that food
I'm like a real cat or like people can
just like retire horses my friends at
the Jazz Club the cool cats oh yeah yeah
yeah this conversation is
okay this guy I mean this teenager
this was his whole case study was
published in the Journal of annals of
internal medicine the annals of internal
medicine thank you
big down so by the age of 17 they
discovered that the boy had suffered
damage to the optic nerve oh no he had
20/200 vision means meaning that he was
legally blind
and so I wasn't completely blind no I
think yeah what that means is at 20 feet
he sees what the average person sees
that by 200 feet or something
well visions calculating 20/20 means
like 20 feet of you see where you're
supposed to see at 20 feet a 2015 that
means that 20 feet you can see what
other people could see at 15 feet so
that means your eyesight is better in
the average person 2,200
it's like someone could see that that
far away you got to be 20 feet in order
to see it
I did not know that I did not know that
either thank you for saying that after
saying the angles and it's followed by
smart [ __ ] or vice versa it has to
happen
so this boy they've tested him and his
nutrients and he was highly deficient in
nutrients including b12 copper it was
the nutrients thing and vitamin D and so
anything even go outside either
well that caused him to have weak bones
and but the weird thing is that he did
develop normally in terms of average
height weight and BMI it's just that he
did know he wasn't obese yeah he didn't
have nutrients though did he was eating
a lot of like energy heavy no nutrients
for one of you to take that stuff with
in like two multivitamins what he had
been normal some Flintstones vitamins
yeah yeah cuz it seems like all that
stuff he's missing you can just have
that at Danny vitam you know just take
one vitamin that's it don't tell him
though cuz you already lost his vision
that's gonna break his heart do my
sister is Jess white that's white right
she's like that level white like Abigail
she was gonna have a getaway so so I was
telling her I'm like she's vitamin D
deficient all the time why don't you get
those plant bulbs just put them in your
house you know they how they grow plants
yeah [ __ ] the Sun gives you vitamin D
it's the combination of eating stuff
with the Sun that activates it based on
calcium calcium and the Sun okay you get
vitamin D in a tanning bed Bart that I
don't know but maybe if you're next to a
window drink some milk get some calcium
aren't there different Ray's like UV
rays use something other black light
like one of those is probably the ones
that you need that you can't get in a
tanning bed I don't know but ask the
lizards whatever they use what's my
third said today or tarantulas supervise
- yeah we're little in El Paso we used
to there's these lizards when you step
on her tale they tell would come off and
they run away yeah and that's what those
were our toys the lizards like that was
use of lizards was your toy we have that
here too is that abuse we would like
Gordon and Stefan you like try and catch
them and step on the tail don't count to
me like that Brooke girl who beat up her
dog you're getting canceled sir okay
that's not getting charged I just saw
that last night watching the dog beating
on it it's been what I have to do I'm
gonna send this video to all 75 cities
before you tour there and they're gonna
know
I saw more violence in that video than I
did in the ASAP Rocky one that's true
I'm sure she has a lot of other videos
that's the stuff she caught on camera
right imagine what just happens in
regular life yeah she had a camera on me
even if she didn't think she was rolling
yeah so the cameras are spitting I will
say is not animal abuse I thing depends
on how hard is spit pretty hard with you
you spit on a person that'd be abuse
it's a dog they don't even know it's
more it's a salt yeah it's a salt it's
really not even know it's more I don't
know it's an Intel you a lot more than
you think they don't know it's an insult
when a cat would know that's like
flipping off a dog it's like well that's
pretty [ __ ] up I'm like that doesn't
mean anything
oh yeah now they're saying that was this
boy went blind because of his diet
because they're saying like I said
before that he was just so he has been
going to mental health people like
trying to find out and treat him for
avoidant restrictive food intake
disorder and he's also been prescribed
nutritional supplements but yeah how
many years did it it's like child abuse
that's what I was just gonna ask as a
parent you kind of like I get the like
freedom of letting a kid do his own
thing but under 18 okay bro you gotta
have yes because Mike's kid don't what
you want to eat nothing but we don't
just let him eat like Pringles in and
fries what's worse than this kid so like
let's say I'm sure the parity tried and
like hey you got to eat some salad I eat
whatever right what's worse this where
the parents are just being a little bit
more lenient and so the kid ends up
abusing himself and he's going blind or
beating the [ __ ] out of the kid which is
physical abuse but now the kid has a
well-balanced diet beat the [ __ ] out of
that kid there's only two off because
this kid obviously does not take any
verbal but I mean as a parent you would
take it into your own I'll [ __ ] em up
supplements and say hey dude but this
kid is saying [ __ ] no to all of them I
dis I'm sure this pan has tried
everything if have you talked to a
doctor about this the doctor would say
beat the [ __ ] out of the kid that's why
they have beat
tubes - you [ __ ] get a nice little
[ __ ] veggie juice going on you pour
that [ __ ] down it down his
throat
first you gotta beat the kid up so that
you can get the soft with the mop like
me you know yeah
tenderize that [ __ ] all eyes are gonna
be struggling yeah I'm in a stomach a
couple of times pop blah yeah cuz some
kids they probably just won't listen you
want me to beat up Isaac for you and no
no you eat everything I know
yeah it's not Vicki anymore well but
yeah so they're saying that well what's
worse stuff do you guys obviously blind
child is worse the only choices I have
yeah yeah the only choices you have you
can make up your own choice Elena
benefits that she tried her best and
they chastise they've grounded they've
got dude her kid went blind cuz he ain't
nothing but [ __ ] food yeah they did all
that they didn't try their best
who exactly like who's providing that
food for them well it's a Bart's point
what if the parent was like okay one of
the things that I'm not gonna buy that
stuff ever and then the kids just not
gonna eat you know so then yours is like
the kid woman is even worse than the kid
Mexican standoff it dies in seven days
my mom was like you're going to you're
going to bed without dinner cuz you're
not eating your dinner I was like good
cuz this [ __ ] sucks ass anyway and then
the next day I'm [ __ ] starving
oh yeah whatever I did that [ __ ] I was
like I don't want this on a hamburger
she was like you don't have to eat and I
was like what nope and it she took my
[ __ ] fade away and then I was like
I'm hungry does she's like nope and then
I had to [ __ ] go to sleep cry like a
[ __ ] but I [ __ ] always ate dinner
from that day on it I owe you both
aren't picky eaters either so I'm trying
to put in time I was a big eater when I
was a kid okay just put into the mindset
of someone that is pick I wasn't picky
that is picky
he's [ __ ] and I because you both of you
guys are gonna skip all three meals if
the food isn't appetite no I'm still
gonna starve and I'm still gonna want to
eat something I've been a mini go to
school you can get a sausage or white
bread then no just money to do that also
you would take away the money to fund
not me I'll suck a dick so if your dick
is gonna sauce you up get a get a warm
meal
give me that baloney he'll just suck a
dick period yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]